let's get some practice interpreting
graphs of proportional relationships so
it says the proportional relationship
between the distance driven and the
amount of time driving is shown in the
following graph so we have the distance
driven on the vertical axis it's
measured in kilometers and then we have
the time driving and it's measured in
hours along the horizontal axis and we
can tell just visually that this indeed
is a proportional relationship how do we
know that well the point 0 0 is on this
graph the graph goes through the origin
if we have zero time then we have zero
distance and we can also see that it's a
line that it's a linear relationship if
you have a linear relationship that goes
through the origin you're dealing with a
proportional relationship you could also
see that by taking out some points here
so let's see i'm just eyeballing it so
i'm going to look at where does the
graph kind of hit a very well defined
point well actually at point a right
over here we see that when
when our time is five hours
our distance traveled is our distance
driven is is what is this it's 400
kilometers
400 kilometers and then if we look at
time see this point right over here when
our time is two and a half
when our time is two and a half we see
that our distance driven is 200
kilometers and notice the ratio between
these variables at any one of these
points is the same 400 divided by 5 is
80 and 200 divided by 2.5 is also going
to be 80 or if you want to go the other
way around you have to to go from time
to distance we're multiplying by
we're multiplying we're always
multiplying by 80. in fact we could say
that distance divided by time our
proportionality constant is going to be
80. or if we wanted to include the units
there it might be a little more obvious
that we're dealing with a rate distance
is in kilometers time is in ours 80
kilometers
80 kilometers per hour this is the rate
at which we are driving we are going at
this speed 80 kilometers per hour this
is also the proportionality this is also
the proportionality constant well anyway
with all of that out of the way let's
actually answer the questions
which statements about the graph are
true select all that apply the vertical
coordinate of point a represents the
distance driven in four hours the
vertical coordinate the vertical
coordinate so point a is at the
coordinate five
comma four hundred
now the vertical coordinate tells us how
high to go up how far to move in the
vertical direction that's going to be
the second coordinate right over here so
this is the vertical coordinate
so this right over here tells us the
distance we've driven in four hours so
yes the vertical coordinate of point a
represents the distance driven in four
hours we've driven 400 kilometers so i
like that one i'll check that one
the distance driven in one hour is 80
kilometers
the distance driven in one hour is 80
kilometers well when you just try to
eyeball it off of this off of the graph
here i see after one hour it looks like
it's a little bit more than 75 so yeah
80 seems like a reasonable one but we
see it even more clearly when we look at
the calculation that we did if you take
a distance if you take a distance any
one of these distance 400 kilometers
400 kilometers over 5 hours
tells you that your rate is 80
is 80 kilometers 80 kilometers per hour
and you know this is going to happen for
any point on this line they tell us it's
a proportional relationship and we can
tell visually it's a proportional
relationship it goes to the origin and
it is a line so the distance traveled in
one hour is going to be 80 kilometers it
is going to be 80 kilometers because
we're going 80 kilometers per hour so in
one hour we're gonna go 80 kilometers so
i like that choice as well and of course
i won't pick none of the above because i
found two choices that i i liked let's
do another one of these this is fun
a grocery store
sells cashews the relationship between
weight and cost of cashews is shown in
the following graph and once again we
see it as a proportional relationship it
goes through the origin and it is a line
which statements about the graph are
true select all that apply
the point zero zero shows the cost is
zero dollars for zero kilograms of
cashews yeah zero kilograms of cashews
it's zero dollars yep that makes sense
the point two comma sixty that's this
point right over here shows the cost is
two dollars for sixty kilograms of
cashews
the cost is two dollars for sixty
kilograms of cashews
no this is showing us that the cost is
sixty dollars the cost is
sixty dollars
for
two kilograms for two kilograms of
cashews this axis right over here this
is weight actually if you're measuring
kilograms you're really talking about
mass but anyway i don't want to get too
particular here
but this you have a mass here of two
kilograms so the the the i guess you say
the horizontal coordinate tells you the
mass the vertical coordinate tells you
the cost and that is sixty sixty dollars
so sixty dollars for two kilograms not
two dollars for sixty krill that would
be a deal if you could get if you could
get you know this is kind of what a
medium-sized grown man would weigh 60
kilograms and two dollars for that much
that much cashews that's that would be
an incredible deal so you definitely
want to rule that one out and i'm not
going to pick none of the above because
i already figured out that i liked i
liked the first choice up there
let's just do one more just for good
measure
an employee earns an hourly wage shown
in the graph below find the hourly rate
wage
so we see here in the horizontal axis we
have hours worked and in the vertical
axis earnings we see it's a proportional
relationship
that the that the and that makes sense
the ratio between earnings and hours
should always be constant if we're
earning money at a constant rate we see
it visually we go through the origin and
we're dealing with a line
so there's a bunch of ways that we could
look at it we could say
we could say hours so let's see
hours
hours and then dollars after one hour
we've made forty dollars and just the
fact visually that we know it's a
proportional relationship says hey we're
making forty dollars per hour
forty if we take dollars divided by
hours i'll write it out the units forty
dollars
forty dollars divided by one hour
this right over here is forty
dollars
per hour you could view this as our
proportionality constant or you could
use the rate at which we're earning
money forty dollars per hour and you see
that two hours eighty dollars
two hours eighty dollars eighty divided
by two is forty three hours hundred
twenty dollars three hours one hundred
twenty dollars hundred twenty divided by
three is forty our proportionality
constant is 40 that your earnings
your earnings
earnings
divided by hours
hours is always going to be equal to 40
or you could say that your earnings
your earnings
is equal to if you multiply both sides
by hours is going to be equal to 40
times your hours
your earnings in dollars is going to be
equal to 40 times your hours